[Musik]
was ist das schon wieder für eine folge
leute ganz ehrlich da kommt auch kein
normaler mensch darauf meine damen und
herren herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen video wisst ihr leute ich bin der
meinung dass wir youtuber unsere
reichweite sinnvoll einsetzen sollten
wir sollten die tatsache dass leute uns
zuschauern dafür nutzen über
gesellschaftlich relevante themen zu
reden wie zum beispiel mobbing auf einer
baustelle kann naja was soll ich sagen
sollte letztens hab ich mir wieder
gedacht eigentlich ist es wieder an der
zeit das gespräch über mobbing auf
baustellen in deutschland wieder
voranzutreiben passenderweise und
natürlich vollkommen zufällig kam eine
hilfe der folge online mit namen mobbing
auf dem bau füße instrument einbetoniert
wir werden uns dieses video jetzt
anschauen und wir werden über mobbing
auf deutschen baustellen nicht mehr
schweigen
ob das echt sein
es ist wirklich ein aufnahmeritual davon
habe ich niemals gehört
da ist schon wieder komplett vorbei
wir sind schon mitten auf der baustelle
leute die folge fängt genau so an und
wir sehen hier einen jungen mann der
natürlich von seinen kollegen
eingestellt wird
naja wenn wir kurz die beschreibung
schauen sehen wir auch die story
dahinter stecken soll denn das ist der
den schwarzen hahn ihr würde am liebsten
comic zeichner werden dafür hat aber
seinen vater markus kein verständnis hat
den traumtänzer dazu als azubi in einer
firma zu arbeiten denn ich fühlte sich
den der bauarbeiter war völlig fehl am
platz merkt man
er wurde innerhalb der ersten acht
sekunden einfach schon einbetoniert die
morgen hin weil sie nicht wollen dass so
ein user auf der baustelle karriere
macht doch danny will sein vater
unbedingt zeigen was in ihm steckt und
hielt sich auch nicht vor seiner
heimlichen flamme lara 17 blamieren die
seit kurzem im büro der baufirma
arbeitet perfekt da haben wir alles
dabei leute wir haben live dabei wir
haben mobbing dabei wir haben leute
dabei die einbetoniert werden läuft
da ist so italien eine überraschung für
dich sein aber weißt du was überraschung
denn je
muss das wirklich sein ist das wirklich
ein aufnahmerituale auf jeder deutschen
baustelle wenn da jemand mal anfängt
klar natürlich in dongo das geld seiner
ganzen sache ist wie wenig er einfach so
darüber reflektiert dass er einfach
gerade ein betoniert wird ach so das ist
immer so wenn leute auf der baustelle
anfangen aber dann jungs macht euer ding
betoniert mir die füße ein
was ist das schon wieder für eine folge
leute ganz ehrlich wer hat sich den
scheißdreck schon wieder bei euch
ausgedacht rtl 2 da kommt auch kein
normaler mensch darauf dass man einfach
ein video darüber macht dass leute auf
baustellen einbetoniert werden
ich hätte niemals auf meinen vater hören
sollen und die ausbildung überhaupt hier
beginnen sollen ich habe echt die
schnauze voll und dann noch so eine
scheiße ich habe die schnauze voll gibt
er das interview gerade während er
jersey die füße einbetoniert bekommt
wenn der beton sich setzt ja ich glaube
schon oder
klarer fall das ist die baustelle der
und
[Musik]
jaja meine rede oder auch allgemeiner
gefragt rtl2 was macht ihr da man auch
was mich jetzt auch interessieren würde
leute also ich habe überhaupt keine
ahnung davon aber braucht so beton nicht
so stunden wenn nicht tage zum aushärten
wie lange sitzt dieser junge ist an
dieser stelle
das war halt da was soll ich sagen dass
das ehrensache ich kann es ja nicht
sagen
natürlich es ist ein ernster ist eine
ehrensache einfach dieses junge mädchen
als nicht vor weiteren hat natürlich
keinerlei ahnung davon dass leute halt
einfach einbetoniert werden auf
baustellen
das gehört sich einfach so machen er
sieht das so traurig aus dieser
situation
egal ob sorry also ist scheiße mobbing
auf baustellen in deutschland ist ein
sehr ernstes thema aber du bist einfach
dumm
das ist aber immer so die sache keiner
in diesen rtl2 stories stellt sich
sowohl die grundlegende frage so was
geht ja eigentlich ab ganz ehrlich wenn
ich irgendwo ein kumpel von mir treffen
würde und den werden einfach seine füße
einbetoniert worden
glaubt mir dann hätte ich erst mal ein
paar fragen dass nicht ausgerechnet
laura hier findet ist zum teil peinlich
und außerdem war ich immer schon in lahr
ein verknallt in der schulzeit und sie
denkt bestimmt dass ich mutter bin
einmal ganz kurz stand der woanders oder
jetzt auf einmal sieht man im
hintergrund irgendwie so ein garten oder
eine wiese papua hat er sich einfach
kurz mit seinen einbetonierten füßen
bewegt ach übrigens leute falls euch
gefragt hat warum ich so eine
angstattacke habe ich glaube beim einer
weisheitszahn op im dezember irgendwas
schief gelaufen um eine bake ist in den
letzten tagen und wochen wieder voll
angeschwollen ja nur falls ihr euch
fragt warum heute einen hamster auf die
hilfe folge reagiert presslufthammer
peter aja kleiner potro ist an der
stelle presslufthammer peter ist
eigentlich nicht rtl2 sondern
pornodarsteller
aber ja auch wieder warum er hinterfragt
keiner diese absurde scheiße man hier
wurde einfach ein mensch einbetoniert
und alle tun so als wäre es ganz normal
ich mag toni perfekt ich würde an der
stelle auch keine sorgen machen wenn
jemand der den hochprofessionellen namen
presslufthammer peter trägt einfach mit
dem scheiß presslufthammer in den beton
von den füßen meißeln der ja ich glaub
dir überlebt diese folgerichtig also
ganz im ernst
er hat sich wahrscheinlich selbst an
betoniert klassischer unfall auf dem
baum
kennen sie das auch leute wenn ihr also
eine baustelle vorbei geht und ihr passt
kurz nicht auf und auf einmal fällt ihr
in die baustelle rein rührt beton an
besorgt euch dann in kübel stellt eure
füße den kübel rein und gibt euch den
selbst angerührten beton über die füße
und sitzt dann noch zehn stunden an
einer stelle
ihr wisst wie schnell das passieren kann
ja alles okay das war eine mutprobe und
ist alles okay okay perfekt dass er
jetzt schon wieder raus ganz klar ist
natürlich auch leute wenn man
einbetoniert war und dann herausgelöst
wird sind natürlich die schuhe komplett
sauber
die schuhe die im beton waren sauber wie
nichts die socken sind sauber das bein
ist sauber die hose ist sauer
rtl 2 halo ist alles okay warum zur
hölle ist diese scheiß hose sauber leute
welche schwarze magie ist dass das kann
ich nicht machen
der echt respekt an diese beiden
darsteller die machen das wirklich
besser als 90 prozent aller anderen rtl2
hilfen die darsteller also das ist
wirklich eine der absurdesten folgen er
war ja die folge dreht einfach darum
dass leute auf der baustelle
einbetoniert werden okay aber keiner von
denen verschiedene mine jungs an ihre
bescheide ehre wie sie sagten mir nicht
einfach was los ist ich meine ich wollte
nur helfen und ich mag ihn ja ganz
klassisches jungs problem leute wenn wir
mal wieder von den kumpels einbetoniert
wurde und hätte keinen was sagen darf
weil das ist ehrensache
man kennt ihn dass sein vater leute oder
vater markus 43 geil sein vater feiert
einfach das den sohn gerade einbetoniert
wurde legende der jungs ihr wisst ja
meinen so drängt bald euch an jetzt
komische frage aber könnt ihr vielleicht
ein betonieren wenn du denkst dass das
die letzte probe hastig abgeschnitten
haben wird aber noch einige folgen aber
vertrauen mir einige ich würde ja sagen
dass er sich wehren sollte aber aber das
problem ist dass scheinbar man
mindestens 120 kilo wiegen und breit
gepumpt sein muss um auf baustellen zu
arbeiten denn die dagegen kämpft er so
in der 50 kilo klasse also vielleicht
die über den ball flach halten
sein vertrag als gut klar wir die sache
klar läuft wurde danny ja alles gut
stop stop okay das reicht das geht zu
weit liebe bauarbeiter wenn es sein muss
riskiert leben und gesundheit von euren
kollegen und betoniert die ein das ist
kein problem aber wenn einer zum check
ansetzt dann den hier zu machen
es geht einfach nicht und das ist genau
das worüber ich geredet habe mobbing auf
deutschen baustellen ich sage zu dem
thema nur eins kleine rohre wenn ihr auf
dich hab ich gerade komme mit meinem
freund siehst du die kiste mit dem
zement ph
wie müsste einmal bitte bei uns ins
fahrzeug gelagert werden dann nimmst du
dir diese eisenstangen komplett einmal
bitte komplett andere in der baustelle
die ja ok sehr gut er kriegt er will
vorher sinnvolle aufgaben gestellt der
liebe der nähe seiner arbeitskraft wird
sinnvoll eingesetzt
jenny ganz kurz siehst du diese diesen
100 kilo sack zement das heißt gut lass
den mal auf den rücken und lauft einfach
damit vier stunden lang um die baustelle
herum schon mal an europäische ich
trinke mit mike noch ein und dann gucken
wir weiter das auch bitte eine e mails
das klischee also es ist herrlich der
tag wahrscheinlich so 13 uhr
und die bauarbeiter ist einfach so geist
kann absaufen
[Musik]
ach da ist was geht jetzt erst mal ganz
kurz wie haben sie diese 130 kilo leute
in fucking opel m reinbekommen und ja
auch was passiert hier ebenso eine
mcdonald's tüten über leute ich würde
sagen wenn ihr wissen wollt wie es hier
weitergeht dann gebt mir in den
kommentaren bescheid checkt hier drüben
ein für ich vorgeschlagen das video aus
und beim nächsten mal wenn einer von
euren freunden einbetoniert wird schaut
nicht weg